well if you haven't started decorating
for Halloween it's not too late
somebody's here to help you I'm joined
by Isabelle Isabella Ruiz of Bella's
party and crafts Boutique and she's got
her kids with her and they have been
carving and having lots of fun making
jack-o-lanterns this morning and you've
done some real magic here which just in
a very short amount of time thank you so
much for being with us thank you for
having me you are a busy lady you're a
mom you and your husband uh coach soccer
yes you do party crafts party supplies
boutiques party planning you are
wonderful so let's think about
jack-o-lanterns and what can people do
to carve that maybe they've never done
before and give us some great tips so
I've got a couple of cool things so we
we like to use the beaters to beat the
little guts out makes it a lot easier a
lot less scraping a lot of times when
you're scraping it hurts your knuckles
instead of using a spoon or whatever you
use that yeah and then you'll just get a
great idea you can use a scooper like an
ice cream scooper scoop it out makes it
a lot easier it goes a lot faster yes
and then another really good tip is
cutting it from the bottom that makes it
a lot easier to put your candle in there
you'll just put it right in and
um
it's so cute yeah and you were saying
that there's also something that you put
inside the pumpkin yes you why did you
bring Vaseline and you brought cinnamon
why did you do that so the Vaseline is
to put it on the creases of the pumpkin
right there it makes it last a lot
longer
um so it keeps it fresher yes it keeps
it fresher okay and then we have it too
and then I have cinnamon cinnamon wheel
just turn it over and you'll dump the
cinnamon up at the top
inside the jack-o-lantern okay
um when you do that it makes it smell
good when you turn on the candle and
then aside from that like it also keeps
pests and rodents away when you put your
jack o'lantern outside of the street
yeah great idea what about the kids all
right let's start let's start with
Steven now he's been using stickers what
an easy way for small kids so much
easier show us Stephen show your
jack-o-lantern to the camera there can
you turn it around show us your
jack-o-lantern the other way to your to
your right honey the other way that way
okay yeah oh sorry I'm sorry to okay so
you've got stickers you've got this
jack-o-lantern how cute oh I love that
what an easy way so you can do all kinds
of faces and then uh as we go to Naomi
and Vicente what are those
jack-o-lanterns they're doing something
you painted one Naomi can you turn your
jack-o'-lantern that way and show the
camera the other way yeah let's look
over here guys uh what did you use on
Naomi's pumpkin there how cute that
looks like a day with a dead yes so
we've got a little kit from Michael's
because every crafter loves Michael's
and Stephen come here Steven here let's
see the pumpkin
that you can do
and um that one's one of the Day of the
Dead ones
that's adorable and what Vicente what
are you working on here Steve I was just
like carving it kind of I was like
trying to make them look scary
nice and you put candles in there is
that what you're gonna do yeah I'm gonna
put candles in there oh looks good all
right all right so many great ideas and
if you want to get into uh some more
details and whatnot uh Isabella has an
Instagram account your Instagram account
Instagram Facebook but at Bella's party
and crafts Boutique
um we do all kinds of partying crafts uh
customized T-shirts customized goodie
bags all kinds of stuff and you've got
great ideas for Halloween thank you so
much for being here thank you for having
us some more ideas at the very end of
the show I'll have a look at your
weekend forecast too that's a not too
spooky yeah when would you come back
thanks a lot for being here thank you
thanks for getting up so early on your
day off we'll be right back everybody